Rides today are obviously more sophisticated than they were...
...even five years ago, ten years ago.
But if you look at the data, you will actually see...
...from 20 years ago until now, you'll see a decrease in the incidence level.
Our industry uses the same software, the same skill set...
...that comes out of the aerospace industry...
...that allows us to make rides extremely exciting but extremely safe at the same time.
Parks have to deal with a variety of challenges...
...like obese and disabled people wanting to ride roller coasters.
A report showed that the teen who died at ICON Park exceeded the ride's weight limit.
We train them to, how to have that tough conversation...
...when somebody may not be eligible to ride a ride for whatever reason that might be.
All of our team members go through what we call verbal judo and tactical communication.
It's for them to learn how to defuse the situation...
...and bring the level down from here back down to an opportunity...
...where we can actually address the issue that is affecting the guests.